[Music]
you are watching the press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive it's time to see what's
making the headlines with conservative
commentator tim montgomery and daily
mirror columnist susie boniface they'll
be with us from now until just before
midnight so let's see what's on some of
those front pages for you now
it's panic at the pumps the male leads
on the long queues at some petrol
stations despite ministers please for
calm
transport chaos spreads reports the
times with icy problems at airport
passport gates also causing delays at
transport hubs
the mirror quotes a retail chief warning
the government has just 10 days to save
christmas with a winter of discontent
looming amid supply shortages
pm relaxes rules for foreign hgv drivers
as on the front of the telegraph with
boris johnson set to relax immigration
rules to tackle the crisis
that's also the lead story for the
express which says the prime minister
has lost his patience
the guardian also goes with that story
the financial times has a similar
headline reporting that 5 000 food
processing workers will also be given
temporary visas in addition to the hgb
drivers
and the star takes a humorous view of
long queues at the petrol stations with
the headline
grumpy pumpy
only the star uh we're joined tonight by
conservative commentator tim montgomery
and daley miraconnis susie bonifacer
welcome to you both um let's start with
with the mail and their headline it's
panic at the pumps uh and uh for once i
have i'm not sure this is overwritten on
my drive into work this evening i passed
probably five petrol stations and the
queues stretched outside
to the road um
is it time to panic susie
well we shouldn't be panicking because
there isn't a shortage
but uh i've got a similar thing i live
in a small village there's an
independent petrol station with a total
of two pumps in it and the village
facebook group tonight is a light with
fury because the entire center of the
village is utterly gridlocked by people
queuing up
for a petrol and there's schools being
settled all over the place uh mail
reports there that police are being
called to some petrol stations mostly
not my one um and this is what happens
when grant shaps goes on television and
tells people not to panic they they do
the opposite of what he says the man is
the kiss of death to a decent public
relations message he should be only
wheeled out in times of absolute
pandemonium i mean wouldn't notice him
anyway
tim
follow that i mean i suppose it doesn't
help when you have um one of the the
petrol suppliers they're full courts
they're limiting and they're rationing
petrol to 30 pounds a maximum that
people can buy apart from the emergency
services and htv um drivers so that then
does feed into the panic doesn't it
it does and i don't think any of your
viewers julian needs reminding of course
you know there's all the toilet roll
hoarding at the start of the the kobe
crisis we do collectively lose the plot
sometimes when we get these um these
stories and uh don't panic don't panic
captain mannering you know it's all part
of the english lexicon really um but the
government will be very very worried
about this i'm old enough to remember i
was a i was a conservative during the
heyday of blair years there was nothing
we could do during that period when
william hague was leader to connect with
the british public but we did as
conservative opposition go briefly ahead
in the opinion polls and that was during
the fuel strike that uh some of your
viewers may remember and that was when
there was trouble getting uh petrol to
the pumps and it cue
you know it created a huge panic across
the country bigger in scale than we've
seen at the moment on this occasion but
people were frightened not just of
course um for their ability to fill up
their own cars but of course we know we
live in an economy which is incredibly
tightly run and if petrol stops arriving
um in the way that it normally does that
work that has implications for hospitals
for the food we get in our supermarkets
and so i think the government needs to
act incredibly quickly in response to
what we're seeing today because
otherwise you know it becomes a
self-fulfilling prophecy where people um
panic buying
uh buying them in quantities that they
don't need at the moment continuing to
create the kind of crisis that we all
want to avoid and i think that's why
measures like tapping people's ability
to buy petrol at 30 pounds a time are
being introduced but
you know it just potentially means that
people visit petrol station down the
road to get another 30 pounds so even
that isn't a uh isn't really a solution
uh meanwhile susie the mirror is uh
setting deadlines ten days to to save
christmas this is according to one
retail chief that's saying unless new
drivers are found in the next 10 days we
will see significant disruption before
christmas
yeah and this isn't really unusual
recent thing
um because you know in 2019
uh the government warned in the house of
lords that there was going to be a
driver shortage with hauliers at some
point in the near future three months
ago already quickly this afternoon three
months ago uh the industry retail
industry wrote to the prime minister and
said we're going to have issues at
christmas with deliveries we need to get
this fixed now two months ago that it
was reported the government was looking
into perhaps letting hgv drivers get
visas to come over from europe and that
went nowhere
um four weeks ago the haulage industry
wrote a letter open letter to the prime
minister's screaming blue murder that
exactly this was going to happen
and in fact if someone sent me that
today five years ago in 2016 back when
chris
i'm an amazing minister grayling was in
charge of the department of transport
they published a report talking about
all the structural problems within the
hgv within the haulage industry the
problems with using cheap foreign labor
and agency staff the fact they could not
retain staff so there was a constant
churn and there was a constant reduction
in the number of hgv drivers available
they have known about this
for at least five years if not longer
brexit has been the straw that broke the
camel's back on all of it because it
means we don't have foreign drivers
coming in from elsewhere to pick up some
of the slack it's harder for them to
come in and we're not getting the same
uh
work we said our hot holiers are broad
so this was always on the it's always in
the cars it's always coming down the
line and this has happened now boris
johnson is saying today or letting it be
known letting it been briefed out is on
the front some of the front pages that
he will allow 5 000 emergency visas to
be given for hgv drivers that's dandy
except we're 90 000 drivers short and
issuing a visa does not make an hgv
driver turn up like that it takes weeks
or months to recruit and train and move
people and bring them across borders and
in the meantime as the mirror is
reporting there green again is fixed in
10 days which is impossible
christmas is kaput
and tim forgive
forgive the pun but this uh does seem to
have been coming down the road for an
awfully long time um this is a massive
u-turn this easing of visas for truck
drivers isn't it
it's a massive u-turn and it isn't i
have a lot of sympathy actually with
what susie has just said you know 10 000
uh visas
isn't going to solve the fundamental
problem
sorry susie 5 000 10. that's 5 000 yes 5
000 for hgv yes 5 000 for poultry
workers so yes it isn't going to solve
the fundamental problem that the country
faces at the moment i think we're much
more likely to see progress i think lots
of hgv companies are trying to get you
know retired or part-time drivers to
work full-time to come you know back to
the the forefront of this uh
for of this challenge i think there is a
problem with tests you know one of the
big reasons main reasons i think we're
in this situation and i accept that
brexit is a contributing factor as a
brexit supporter but the main reason
let's be absolutely clear is the fact
that we've had covid and lots of uh
people who've been would have otherwise
qualified as hgv drivers in britain
haven't been able to qualify we need to
fast track those tests to get people
onto the road as soon as possible and
overall i would have some sympathy with
the government's reluctance
to bring to introduce um extra visas for
people overseas because that is how the
haulage industry over time has kept the
wages of drivers low the government's
general desire not to bring in foreign
workers has been to protect the wages of
british workers and give them a better
deal so it's a reluctance that a lot of
people will have sympathy with i think
yes and susie we read in the uh ft that
that basically the prime minister's had
his arm bent on this and he he's bowed
to months of of pressure this is not
something that he wanted to do
no uh and it's it's a similar thing you
know to lock down it's something being
done late because he's been made to do
it and therefore it's too late and it's
not going to work if you've got to do it
and if you've got to do something that
ideologically or personally you don't
fancy you know rip the plaster off do it
early make sure it actually works if you
have to do this thing don't leave it
till the 10th minute you know if people
had paid more attention to what boris
johnson's career was like as a
journalist all we'd have had to do was
speak to the sub editor who had to have
his columns delivered late and with a
skid mark right across the page and
which held up everybody else on the
paper trying to get their own lives and
things organized and causing costs and
delays for everybody else if you can
just see someone who is a journalist
right as a columnist one of the most
useless people on the planet and i am
one if they're acting that badly and
without disrespect for the way the whole
machinery and everything else works
around them how on earth are you going
to put them in charge running an actual
cupcake
we need a tally we've grant chaps uh
chris grayling boris johnson they've all
sort of been blamed by susie for this
crisis let's be clear there may be some
blame too
allocated but look across europe you
know there are hgv driver shortages
across the whole of the continent poland
i think has a hundred thousand drivers
sure this is a problem that is
complicated and not amenable to sort of
easy simple uh solutions christmas will
not be put despite scrooge suzy's uh
warnings there will be some extra prices
that all of us unfortunately will have
to pay it's one of the reasons why i
don't think the government should be
cutting universal credit at this time
but that's another story but you know we
will have christmas there'll just be
unfortunately some extra niggles
associated with it and after what the
world economy has just been through
because of the covid crisis if people
expected smooth sailing in every walk of
life then they were fooling themselves
we've just been through one of the most
dramatic episodes in our history and
there are bound to be complications and
the shortage of hgv drivers is one of
the most
significant manifestations of that so
far susie's shaking her head but tim you
got the last word there just before the
the break
that thumbs up do stay with us
it's tim go on then you have the last
words so what was that oh it's julian
either
shortages across europe but nowhere else
in europe not in ireland not in poland
tim has empty shelves or petrol
shortages that's just here where just
one thing's that really is the last word
for now that really is the last word for
now uh stay with us we're going to take
a break coming up as the labour
conference starts the deputy leader
shares her views on fixing the social
care crisis
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview with me the conservative
commentator tim montgomery and daily
mirror columnist susie boniface welcome
back to you both um let's have a look at
the um mirror now uh and this is the
deputy leader of the the labour party
angela rainer we
read in the previous papers 10 days to
save christmas but she's saying it would
take 20 days to save social care would
there be a labor government
tim
yeah like this is the beginning of
course of a very important labour
conference for kia stammer and i think
there will be
quite a lot of people looking at angela
rayne as the possible alternative leader
if kia stammer fails they have a
notoriously a testy relationship and
angela rayner is obviously making a
pitch which is really central to british
politics at the moment it wasn't so long
ago that boris johnson
put forward his uh pledge to deal with
the crisis in social care there's a
story elsewhere in tomorrow's paper in
the times with um local government
leaders already saying that the money
that he's pledged or won't be enough to
uh sort out the crisis they're talking
about potentially a nine percent
increase in council tax in order just to
plug the funding gap in social care and
so here we have labour's deputy leader
putting forward her own ideas and of
course we would all support the higher
wages for care home workers that she is
advocating in this interview that would
come through a compulsory form of wage
negotiation i'm not entirely clear how
she will pay for it but that's a common
problem with most labor policies
susie she's got some credibility in this
space though hasn't she because she's a
former agency care worker
yeah she doesn't know what she's talking
about which makes a pleasant change from
so many people who are in the government
who are working on something that's not
their specialism shall we say um and
what she's saying when i read that
headline about 20 days to fix social
care and like my jaw hit the floor and i
thought what that's going to take a lot
longer than that love um but actually
what she's talking about is that within
the first 20 days she would push through
some legislation which would make it
mandatory that employers and workers
would negotiate their pay and so she
says that she sees that's a win-win for
bosses and for staff everyone gets a
work-life balance everyone gets better
at comparing conditions and they they
get happier staff as a result and they
get more productive stuff as a result so
it seems perfectly sensible and
reasonable elsewhere in that be she's
talking about it's a big interview it's
quite wide ranging and she's talking
about how she wants to go for the top
job and get to downing street and it
sounds as well like she very much wants
to take boris johnson on one to one and
the two of them are very similar in some
ways they're both sort of unspinable uh
and they're not happy to do what other
people would advise them to do uh you
know in terms of what their press
officers might say so
you know uh she she's not kiyostama
let's put it that way no she is not uh
very quickly we've just got time to talk
about uh emma radekanu playing with
royalty today tim very quickly yeah
the lovely photograph on the front page
of the telegraph but of course i think
two weeks ago we were celebrating a huge
win and she's already axed her coach and
maybe that's what you need to stay at
the top of sport that kind of
ruthlessness but it's a big gamble by a
very young player good luck to her
though is all i can say
susie
i don't like the use of the word
ruthless
all tennis players when they break
through tend to change their coaching
team just had a look when andy murray
split from evan lindell that was ending
his partnership when he split with
aurelie maresma that was susie
susie and tim we have run out of time
thank you so
much both we'll see you in the next hour